all right at 6 38 now there is a switch
here to a beloved spin-off to that
Miracle on Spring Mountain at Sand
Dollar Lounge the fully immersive
holiday experience is back but there's a
Twist we have Candace Charles live this
morning over at the Sand Dollar Lounge
on Spring Mountain live with a look
Candace good morning to you
good morning Jack good morning folks yes
hundred thousand dollars
dollar corner right now lots of
different drinks for you to cheers to of
course eggnog and I'm joined by the
bartender Nick Butler thank you so much
for joining us explain the miracle and
Spring Mountain experience so Miracle
Spring Mountain uh you come in we've got
10 different specific cocktails for the
season we open at 2 p.m every day until
4 a.m live music every single day at 10
p.m
um we've got some great uh Pizza Kitchen
we have some great uh local chefs coming
in to do some pop-up stuffs um so the
proceeds are not gonna go to charity
it's just a really fun event all for the
rest of the year yeah it sounds like
it's gonna be a great time and if you
want something that's a little bit more
tropical fulfilling that it's too cold
there's something a little special for
you at the new sand dollar Lounge on
Maine tell us about it yeah of course if
you are we have a second location now
it's down in The Plaza Hotel on Main
um they're running a program called Sip
and Santa it's gonna be more kind of
like a tiki kind of tropical Vibe as
opposed to our more like you know eggnog
hopping around with style drinks
um but yeah if you like you said you
feel something a little bit lighter a
little bit more tropical that would be
the way to go awesome it sounds like
it's
good someone perform the performances
start on Thursday here they have a huge
ugly sweater party on Saturday so break
out that sweater if you can and of
course you can come on down and get the
pizza pop-up starting on December 5th
now this goes all the way into Saturday
December 31st so lots of time to come on
down here and enjoy and of course we got
to cover with all details on our website
8newsnow.com for now live from the
Spring Mountain I'm Candace Charles 8
news now Candace thank you very much I
can see you're already enjoying some of
the uh the concoctions already this
morning so that's one way to wake up
right get you nice and early
love it all right Candace thank you very
much